okay now we're going to do the lab for
chapter 12 which is unsupervised
learning and we'll in particular
demonstrate principle components in
clustering so at the beginning of the
lab we import libraries just like we've
done before and by now is very familiar
um and some new some new libraries and
functions um that get imported as well
including some that are have been made
for the islp
package um for the princip principal
components we're going to work with a
USA arrest data which is actually a data
set in the r Computing environment and
there's a nice python function called
get our data set which can be used to
get um retrieve data from our packages
and that's what we use here that's quite
a nice feature in that you can compare
methods in both R and python though
we're not talking about R in this course
it's it's nice to see to be able to
compare them and R has a lot of free
data sets buil bu in as well and you can
see it it delivers a um a data frame and
it's uh it's only got four variables um
which we using to demonstrate principal
components principal components ideally
you know is used to reduce um very wide
data set when you got lots of variables
lots of correlations but here we just
using four variables and the four
variables look at different crime rates
in in each of the states in the country
um so the Roso States and the crime is
broken down um by percent of crimes that
are murder assault and and rape in in
each state and uh actually not percents
but um rat of some kind rates of some
kind yes and uh and then there's also
[Music]
um fourth variable which is the percent
of the population in the state that's
Urban yeah
so there's there's the the 50
states
um so the columns are the four
variables um we can compute the means of
of of of each of the variables
um we can also examine the variance of
the four variables oh I noticed that
some there's quite a bit of difference
in the in the variance there I wonder if
that might make a difference in the in
the principal components yes so
principal components like um red
regression and lassu um it's an
unsupervised learning method but um it's
sensitive to the scaling of the
variables it's looking for linear
combinations of the variables with large
variance if we just used it on the data
as is you can see the ass salt variable
um which has a large variance on its own
is going to get a lot of weight in the
in in the components because it's got
high variance so what we usually do is
is standardize the the data and we're
going to use our standard scaler again
with standard deviation and with mean so
we're going to Center the data and and
standardize to have each of the
variables have unit standard
deviation and we so we've defined the
Scala and then we we do a fit and
transform on the USA rests and we give
oursel a new data frame USA arore
scaled now we're going to PR you perform
principal components on
them
um and so we Define PCA us as as this
PCA function um from sklearn and we fit
it on the USA rest scale data and that's
computed our principal components for us
so Trevor I noticed here that the fit
method it just seemed to take an X
Matrix and I guess that's because this
is a Transformer instead of an estimator
all right see like a classifier would
have a or regression would have a label
right yes yeah I see good point yeah so
that reminds you that principal
component is unsupervised so there's no
response
um we can uh we can compute the mean um
of the of the principal
components um oh this gives you the
means of the variables and we see that
they're all zero as we expect cuz we did
the same Trend and scaling yeah so I
think what PCA might if you had not
Stander it itself it would Center it for
us and we would might see nonzero but we
already removed the mean so yeah so now
having computed the principal component
you can extract things such as the
scores those are often what we
interested in
and and uh and we get those by using the
fitted principal component model to
transform the data Matrix that we the
data frame that we provide Ed and that
gives us the transforms to the principal
component scores
okay
and and uh and then the components are
the direction vectors that Define the
principal components now we got four
variables in our data frame so we can
get at most four principal components
and here we've computed them all and the
rows of these components are the the
direction vectors so how much weight to
give to each of the the four variables
um so each each row is a different
principal component
MH so the one of the things we like to
do with principal components is is plot
the data um and in particular plot the
leading principal components and it's
often common to make a two-dimensional
plot because that's something you can
visualize nicely and so here we set up
some code for doing that um with and
labeling the axes and and so on sure I
think this one you you might see this
called a b plot in some place is that
right it's called a b plot yeah okay and
let's just look at the plot and and and
you you'll see that code produced this
plot here and the reason it's called a b
plot is because it's both plotting the
principal components it's also plotting
the um these little line segments here
is is is showing um is representing the
coefficients of the directions right so
you see them both in one plot M now so
that's the code for producing this plot
if you look in the textbook you'll see
the B plot for the same data um that
this picture is upside down relative to
that picture and that's because the
scores in the principal component you
can multiply any of the scores for any
of the components by minus one and the
variance doesn't change and principal
components is all about variance so
principal
components is
is gives you a solution up to sign flips
on each of the components so we can redo
this plot by flipping the sign on the
second component and we do that and that
gives you a picture that looks exactly
the same as the one in the in the book
we've also applied a bit of scaling to
the to the the little line vectors um to
to make them occupy more of the the
frame the the plottin axes so I'm
wondering how to inter purpose so it
looks like the urban pop is sort of
vertical so maybe this axis is
separating population states by how
Urban they are and then the the Left
Right seems to be sort of like a you
know a violent crime or not AIS is that
how that's exactly right yeah and that's
exactly what you do Jonathan you look to
see for each of these these variable
lines how aligned they are with either
of the coordinate axes in these plots
and that helps you name the plot so so
so in this case it gives you a very nice
interpretation
um and there's various other things you
can extract from the the fitted
principal component um object um one
thing people like to look at is how much
variance is explained by the components
because you're trying to do a data
reduction okay and so we we're
interested in the
variance and and not the and so what we
what we have here is this actually
computes the variance of each of the
components and they necessarily must be
decreasing because the the first
principal component has maximum variance
the next one second maximum and so on
and because the data was standardized
these variances must add up to four
because the original
variances the the the were one for each
of the variables and a property of the
principal components is that the sum of
the variances of of the solutions give
you the the the original sum of
variances um what's often more
interesting is the percent variance
explained and so that we've computed at
the bottom here and you see that the
first principle component explains 62%
of the
[Music]
variance um the the second principle
component explains a further uh 28% of
the varant and then the remaining two
principal components explain much less
quite small yeah so we're going to make
a plot to show both the variance
explained and the percent variance
explained
and and this plot is going to have two
subplots because we're going to have two
plots in a row okay and so we what we've
done here is we first produced the first
plot that's code for the first plot
which is proportion of variance
explain um and then in the second plot
it's going to be cumulative proportion
of of variance
explained and we want to plot them both
and so what we've done here is we've
used this percentage percentage capture
which lets you produce a plot but not
display it right away just hold it and
then you can add your second plot and
then you can um display the whole figure
which you just do by typing fig and so
there you see the two plots yeah I guess
without that capture we would have after
the first line we would have seen two
plots well the one on the left would be
have the uh the variance ratio but we
wouldn't have filled in the second one
and it would be blank would it yeah we
we haven't plotted anything to that axis
so this is a that's a way of doing them
both and I'll just say one th this
percent percent these things are called
Magics uh so there are various there
percent percent capture is one of them
but they're often there're some handy
ones and actually we mentioned r a
little bit earlier you can actually run
there's an R magic that you can run R
code in Python we're not going to talk
about it today but that's these Magics
of the of
IPython okay so that's that's the end of
principal components we're going to
leave you to read the the section on
Matrix completion where you can use
Matrix uh principal components as a
means for filling in missing data in a
in a data Matrix but you can we leave
that for you to do on your
own